- This is the thing. This show isn't live.
That's a whole different situation,
when you're doing live stuff.
Like when I host award shows,
it's a different animal.
So out of The Today Show all those years,
like what was your most
favorite unplanned moment?
- Well, I have a lot of 'em, you know,
but I did the show for 15 years, I think.
Well, one time a woman exposed
herself when she was out
on the Plaza and the rest of the anchors.
- Did you throw her beads?
- No, bu I was on a remote location
and the rest of the anchors,
she was behind them,
so they didn't see anything.
So basically you saw me in the box going.
So that was great.
I mean, there'd been a lot.
And then I was interviewing Barbara Bush
at the White House for the
anniversary of the White House.
And we were getting a whole
tour and suddenly her husband,
President George Herbert Walker Bush,
walked in with their dog.
And I had to do an impromptu
19 minute interview
that I hadn't prepared for.
- I bet those 19 minutes lasted forever.
- Oh my god. I was so fitted
out and it was so stressful.
And I kept thinking, I'm
gonna run outta questions.
I'm gonna start asking him
"What's your favorite food
here in the white house?".
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- You know, but it all worked out.
- Oh, that's so cool though.
That's a really cool
impromptu kind of interview.
- Yeah.
- Nobody gets that chance often.
- I knows it was funny.
I can't believe that he decided to walk in
in the middle of our
interview, but he did.
And it was great.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- That was when I had first
started on The Today Show.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- So it was a big moment for me yeah.
- [Kelly] Like "welcome" (laughs).